Welcome.
My name's David, and I want to introduce
you to ARC.
ARC is available in most Linux and Unix
based distributions.
This is the version I'm running.
And if we take a look at the
main page, what we'll see is ARC scripts
are formed of patterns and actions.
A combination of patterns and actions allow us
to do some pretty cool things on the
command line that would otherwise be rather cumbersome.
So let's take a look at PS.
This outputs all of the processes running on
my system.
And normally, you may wish to pipe to
grep or Firefox.
We can replicate this behavior with ARC like
this.
This is regex syntax to filter on a
string Firefox.
Now because we didn't specify an action, the
default action is to print zero,
everything.
However, we can change that and get automatic
column splits with ARC.
Let's print the username, the process ID,
we'll count along,
we'll also print the time the process started
as well as the full command.
Excellent.
Now
we can see that these columns reflect what
we wanted without having to specify any additional
logic.
But let's tidy up this output.
We can use a begin block to set
some global variables
and we're going to specify that the output
field separator should be three tabs.
That looks a lot better.
Okay. What if we were working with other
data types?
What about CSV or something that looks like
CSV?
Let's use the password file.
Now we can cat that file,
pipe it to ARC,
and attempt to do something similar.
First, we'll just start by printing everything,
which works just the same.
Now let's print the username column,
the user ID column.
We'll also print the username,
their home directory,
and their shell.
Drats, it doesn't work and that's because the
field separator is no longer space or tabs.
So we can use the begin block once
more, only this time instead of setting the
output field separator,
we'll set the field separator
we are going to use a colon
and you can see that works nicely.
Now let's filter this data.
Instead of using a regex like last time,
we're actually going to do a numerical comparison
and filter on the user IDs above 400.
Now one last thing about AUK, it has
a standard library.
You can see here we're using to upper
on our username.
We're gonna calculate the length
of our actual name, as well as printing
out our name.
Perfect. You can see the uppercase,
we can see the string length, and everything
works as expected.
ARC is a pretty cool tool.
You only have to learn a few things
to get a whole lot of value back.
Enjoy.